One of the fundamental features of
a prototype is that it acts vaguely like
the final app when it's interacted
with but is much simpler to make.
This means that when
we build a prototype,
we need to think about
interaction points.
An interaction point is anywhere that
a user might might press, scroll, or
type in order to interact with your app.
By identifying
the interaction points for
your app, you will identify where you
need to link screens together and
what work you need to do
to build a prototype.
For a low fidelity prototype,
we only need to deal with interaction
points that will move the user between
the screens, not interaction points
that will allow them to input content.
For example, let's take a look at
our calendar and to do list app.
This app had a floating action button,
or FAB, which we can expect users to
touch and on the screen that opens,
it has a number of other options.
We can expect users to try to interact
with each of them in the final app but
since they don't add another screen,
we don't need to deal with that
functionality here just yet.
On our menu screen,
each item leads to a new screen.
Fewer menu items means fewer screens to
build but also a reduced functionality.
Finding a balance there is vital,
we don't want to remove an core
functionality in order to have fewer
interaction points but you can probably
go without a terms and condition
option in your lo-fi prototype.